Ronda santis came locked and loaded he
hit Nikki Haley for being a squish he
said that she marched with the blmr and
if not literally at least in rhetoric
that she bought into the left-wing
talking points of the last three five
years and the conservatives can't trust
her Nikki Haley and I have a
disagreement on the BLM stuff too
because she tweeted during this period
of time that the death of George Floyd
should be quote personal and painful for
each and every American but people in
Iowa had nothing to do with that or
Florida or South Carolina she was virtue
signaling to the left she was accepting
the narrative and she was trying to
impress people who are never going to
like us I never bought in to going after
the police we back the blue to the Hill
State of Florida and we're we're we're
about lower crime as a result of that
thank you Governor Haley it's a good hit
it was a nice attack especially in Iowa
which is pretty conservative place